jose suarez 7a looking to even up that
record with an 8-8 mark solid array
3.67 got him
it's a nice battle right there and a
good start for suarez well he did go
after with that that's a really good
change up there's one away that'll bring
up first baseman ty france he's ready to
bust down he hits this one high deep
left center field carry on carry out
there it is one nothing mariners in the
first inning
ty france with his 18th home run rbi
number 66 in the mariners break on top
got it on a 2-1 pitch well you had to
feel that this was a good matchup for ty
france i think the hit swerves you have
to stay towards the middle of the field
and if he makes a mistake with a
breaking ball or the change up you can
take advantage of it and that's exactly
what happens with ty france
that's a little flare right field walsh
over that's a heck of a play
boy to go back at that angle to run over
there dealing with the that little short
wall by the seats right along the foul
line good play
suarez right back to him
he's able to get out of the inning logan
gilbert on the mound for the mariners
tonight getting ready for his 23rd start
of the year he's been absolutely
outstanding since coming up from aaa
tacoma where he made only one start this
year one two here to marsh he could not
hold up that's a strikeout one down
swinging and missed some high heat two
down well he showed him everything we
saw a curve ball at 77 the slider at 85
and then how about 97 again up out of
the strike zone working ahead getting
them chase
they did since alan porter so logan
gilbert striking out the side here in
the bottom of the first getting marsh
ohtani and gosling and that's it for the
halos what a start for gilbert well we
go to the top of the third tonight from
southern california it's the mariners
one of the angels nothing 3-1 to tom and
he's aboard first walk by suarez
hit hard and fletcher starts the double
play
too much speed to get dylan moore but
that's well done by david fletcher to
luis lenipo top of the owner here's jp
for the second time
jp the other way to the gap
dylan moore digging hard he's going to
get the third it's bobbled out there man
he'll put up the stop sign jp hustles
into second there he goes second and
third for the mariners here in the third
a chance for ty france to pick up a
couple more runs
get it the other way
face hit
rojas gets it back in dylan moore scores
going to third is jpg crawford a line
drive smash to right field for ty france
he drives in another run
it's ty france two and the angels
nothing great start for ty france two
rbis two nothing mariners runners at the
corners here in the third for mitch
hannigan with the third booted they get
one they won't get the double play
scoring is j.p crawford as mitch hanigar
drives in a run and the mariners add to
the lead it's now three to nothing here
in the third
seeger high fly ball
phil gosselin has it
for the third out of the third inning a
couple of quick outs recorded here by
gilbert
matter now will be
jose rojas
line drive right field he's a doubles
machine
rojas
into second base
and that's a two out double his 14th
double of the year
angels have had doubles the last two
innings against gilbert but have not
been able to get the
runner past second
backstassie runner and scoring position
jose rojas rope to double
drive that ball was hit well by max
stassi
it is gone
two-run home run for max dassey and the
angels are right back into this 3-2 oh
he went his percentage that he has
thrown a slider in that spot that's that
hanging slider
466 slugging against the pitch now
eighth home run allowed versus his
slider
this season as dominant as this fastball
has been is slided on occasion has been
a mistake pitching that was a mistake
pitch
and maximus
entertaining us with a two run home run
the champion kyle seeger luis terrence
three four five
that's hit well left field and misjudged
over the head of goslin
haniger
into second a lead off double here in
the sixth mitch's 23rd double that's
gonna do it for jose suarez pitching
change as kyle seeger sets in
gets him kijata right back showing some
emotion that is a big out mitch
hanigaard second base so the hitter now
will be turins their
designated hitter
pitch up in his eyes dropped it into
center field and he's going to score and
the memories have a 4-2 lead
how about luis terrence rbi number 45
this on the heels of his first big
league pinch hit
home run yesterday good work
helmet hits that one left field phil
gosselin on his horse
he's able to run it down that's a nice
catch
runner going to third terence makes it
first and third now two down
struck him out jimmy herget comes in and
gets the job done murphy goes down
angel's getting ready to step up as we
move to the bottom of the sixth four to
two seattle one down and that's it well
line drive bases it
for jack mayfield
he's had himself a great series versus
the astros
and gets himself his first knock of the
night
had a feeling he was gonna walk him
great job by jose rojas to draw that
walk and that's gonna do it for logan
gilbert from our angel joe smith 37
years old 14 seasons been around a long
time
and he's got to face
max stassi
and there's stasi not wasting any time
line drive right field
here comes jack mayfield he scores it's
4-3 rojas to third base
and the angels creep a little closer i
tell you what stassi is squaring the
baseball up tonight yeah rojas able to
go first to third on that so
great opportunity right here for the
angels to tie this ball game up renjifo
first pitch swinging
with only one down rojas
tagging up
and he is going to tie this game up nice
job
max stassi
stays at first luis
renee fo gets the job done rolos comes
in we're tied up jake fraley
will be the pinch hitter to start the
inning for the m's look out
did get him elbow and here's the top of
the order jp crawford will stand in
and jp a liner to the gap fraley can run
he's at second heading to third here's
the throw to third not in time jp to
second there you go joe madden gonna
make a another pitching change
nobody out runners at the corners ty
france hot header two rbis a home run
tonight
bouncing ball randy fall here's a throw
to the plate wide run scores matters
take the lead jp to third going to
second to throw down the second ty
france came off the bat sure did he's
out but the good news the mariners have
a 5-4 lead and they have crawford on at
third base with one out in the inning
here comes mitch hanigar who doubled
last time
off the label
should be plenty deep
j.p
coming home
there's the throw he's in with a head
first dive and the mariners have a two
run lead sac fly mitch hanniger second
rbi tonight well done bottom seven six
four mariners over the angels two out
two on
jack mayfield coming up clutch once
again it is six to five here in the
bottom of the seven
mayfield once again delivers with two
outs he's done it the last two nights
add tonight to the list
and he was having a good at-bat here and
this fastball 95 on the outside part of
the plate he goes right with it
popped it up
playable seeger's under it
america's go to the eighth inning up by
a run
it is fall seawall time here in the
ninth
hit well
haniger one out
scott service after falling behind two
and oh says walk him again that's the
second time that the maritals have
intentionally walked ohtani tonight so
gosling is the batter he's not going a
little flare to right field that's going
to drop ohtani is going to third base
and the goose is loose into second for a
double
second and third one out
intentional walk now
to jared walsh to load him up
got him two down that's a perfect slider
went right to it hadn't shown it to him
yet the key is to locate with it and he
was going to make sure this is off the
edge of the plate and that's exactly
right this is perfect
ground ball to tie france
race to the bag and a murders win this
ball game six to five
the mariners have now won six in a row
and they remain two back in the wild
card race behind the yankees
you